what's that believe nation its Evan my
one word is believe I believe in you and
I want to see that awesomeness inside
you explode out into the world so you
can do something crazy special now to
help you on your journey today we're
going to talk about seven ways to stay
focused at work so one of the things
entrepreneurs have a really hard time
with is staying focused right we we love
dreaming we love come up with ideas we
love doing all sorts of different things
something comes into our head and we
want to go and chase that we love shiny
objects and then you're not doing the
thing that you're supposed to do and so
today I'm gonna talk about how do you
stay focused what are my seven ways to
help you stay focused at work so we
number one is have a schedule and goals
I find that really helpful to know
here's what I'm gonna do today here's
what's on my schedule here's here my
goals for the day here's what I want to
accomplish and every morning I load up
my calendar and I say okay today is
YouTube day I click on the note it
reminds me of what my goals are for that
day and my goals are in general like
here's what I wanna compliment if
channel next goal hit a million
subscribers how do I do that what are
the things I need to work on improve and
just a reminder of here's what I need to
do because I find that what helps is you
have days when you're creative and
thinking and brainstorming on how to
improve but most of your day should be
execution most view they should be doing
the work of what you planned and so I
plan all these sayings I don't
necessarily remember everything and so
having it in my calendar really helps I
look at that in the morning and then I
go and start executing against it now
you will have some days where you just
come up with this insanely great idea
and you're in the flow and you're in the
zone and you need to go off and do that
thing and I encourage it and I do it
myself and I'll throw everything else
aside to say this is what I'm doing
today when you're in the flow you have
to stay there because you can create
gold but most of the days you're not in
the flow most of days you wake up like
okay what am i doing today and I think
if you wake up with that mindset of I
don't know what I'm gonna do today that
may work for some people for me I find
that having a schedule having goals
knowing what I want to accomplish today
and having that kind of setup for me and
my calendar so I don't have to think
about it in
morning gives me a lot more focused work
say this is my YouTube day here's what I
got accomplished let's go let's get it
done
[Music]
number two is start the day off right
this is a recurring theme in a lot of my
videos I think you need to have a
routine it sets you up for success every
single day so it's a matter of setting
goals and then following through on
those goals and what happens with a lot
of people is you wake up and what
happens the alarm goes off and a lot of
people hit this news button right you're
hitting the snooze button and so like
the first thing you've done is you've
set a goal to wake up at whatever 7
o'clock 8 o'clock
you said it going and wake up at 7
o'clock you hit the snooze button the
first thing you've done in the morning
is let yourself down you set a goal you
said it's okay if I don't hit that goal
I'll do it later so that's what you're
training yourself to do is the first
thing you do every day is you set a goal
and then you don't hit the goal and
that's okay so how's the rest your day
gonna go you think you're gonna stay
focused at work when the first thing you
do is let yourself down on a goal it's
even worse you hit the snooze and then
you hit the snooze again you get the
seems again it's like you've just
trained into yourself that this is great
like you set a goal it doesn't really
matter if you hit the goal nobody's
paying attention so I'll just coast
that's how most people start their day
right it's like get up do the thing that
you're supposed to do stop hitting the
snooze button and set a goal for
yourself
in the morning to build the routine
around what makes you come alive look if
you want to be focused then being around
things that make you feel focused like
what's on the wall what are you gonna
read in the morning what videos gonna
watch what helps you get into a focus
state and then do that every morning
if hugging your cat and and singing a
song makes you focused great like do
that every morning that's how you start
your day find the thing that that you've
had these moments of focus find out what
triggered it maybe you're watching a
video before maybe reading a book before
what was the thing that you were doing
maybe you're meditating or something
else like I'm not judging what you have
to do find that thing and then do that
in the morning everyday instead of
hitting the snooze button start your day
off focused you're much more likely to
be focused the rest of the day and if
you start your day off unfocused
number three's have deadlines it's
amazing how focused you can be when you
have deadlines for what you're supposed
to accomplish and especially if you can
commit to somebody else like I will get
this to you by the end of the day today
you commit to somebody else to do that
you're much more likely to follow
through and probably get that thing done
then if you commit to yourself because a
lot of times we'll let ourselves down
right you say like I'll get that done
and then you don't get it done and who's
gonna hold you accountable well it's
okay it's like hitting the snooze button
in the morning nobody's holding you
accountable and so you don't do it so
having a deadline to say this is what I
need done today you're much more likely
to get it done if Golda's today just
like if you think back to school when
you were studying for exams or having to
do a term paper most of the work happens
close to the end like I still got two
months I don't need to start doing it
now you do a little bit you do a little
bit you do a little bit but you don't
actually get really going until close to
the end I look at my next book as an
example I wanted to come out December 6
I decided when I was on my vacation that
December 6 I launched your one word last
year and my new book that I've been
slowly kind of strumming along making
some progress with side hustle project I
decided I wanted to come up December 6
as soon as I said that deadline
I had the hustle because it wasn't even
close to being ready and then I got all
of the things lined up so that we can be
ready for December 6 and there's still a
lot more work that has to get done but
setting deadlines for things and
especially making them public telling
your friends about it telling people who
follow you on social media telling your
friends on Facebook or committing to
somebody else say I will get this done
for you by this time makes you much more
likely to follow through be focused and
get that work done
[Music]
number four don't respond to emails
first thing in the morning when you get
to work it's easy to fall into the trap
of coming to work opening up your email
checking your phone checking your
Facebook whatever tools do you use to
communicate with your work colleagues
and start to deal with their problems
the problem with that is if the first
thing you do is deal with other people's
problems that's how the whole date is
gonna go realistically most things that
people ask for your help in are not so
urgent that they can't wait two or three
hours and if you first in the morning
you focus on dealing with things you
have to do on dealing with your tasks
you're more capable mentally and more
prepared to help others but if you just
start to respond to emails and you start
to help others before you deal with your
own situations unfortunately you're
gonna live a lifestyle where you're
gonna be out work until 9:00 or 10:00
p.m. only simply because you're so
exhausted dealing with other people's
emergencies they didn't have time to
manage your own affairs you can't help
others until you help yourself so if you
focus on yourself
first you're gonna feel more empowered
to be able to help others and feel less
stressed at your work so carve out 30
minutes an hour in your schedule and set
that standard for all your work
colleagues book off your calendar and
say for this time I'm devoting it to
myself and if you do that you're gonna
find that your days become more
manageable and you stay more organized
[Music]
way number five is eliminate other
distractions so Alex talked about not
answering email in the first couple
hours of getting into work that's a
massive distraction for a lot of people
I would also say look at the other
distractions social media the people
around you your cell phone notifications
flying off look at the things that are
preventing you from doing the work look
at these juicy carrots that are popping
up bright like a little diamond shut oh
I want to go and chase that thing ooh
ooh I want to go chase that thing right
like we have constant distractions but
it's also people in your work like
people coming up and say hey can I want
to ask you this question or hey how
about that game last night or this funny
joke that I want to tell you like if you
need to focus your efforts
then you need to focus your efforts like
you can't reach me during the day most
of the time I'm on Facebook Messenger
for my team that's how they reach me and
they know that I'm busy so like reach me
if there's an urgent message you can hit
me on Facebook otherwise send me an
email and within 24 hours I'll get back
to you otherwise there's no number I
don't the phone number you can't reach
me you know I have an answering machine
service so I only have the number
because for some things you sign up for
you need to have a phone number for them
to call but I don't have a phone number
I don't have a phone I will always call
people using my Google service online
there's no way to reach me there's no
way to distract me from the things that
I'm doing and I'm not perfect at it I
still get distracted by some things but
by thinking about the things that are
really distracting you the most like
what was the last project that you were
trying to work on you know you set aside
90 minutes to go work on this project
did you get the 90 minutes or did you
get 25 minutes and you got distracted by
this and the tract about that distracted
by that just paying attention to what is
causing those distractions and then
figuring out how do I eliminate these
things in my life or how do i schedule
them so that I have this block of time
to work uninterrupted on my project
especially you in creative work it's
really really hard when you get
distracted when I was working on writing
this book I went to Whole Foods I went
to a cafe and I spent the whole day
there and you couldn't reach me because
if I'm writing my book and I get
distracted by something and I let my
team know I let my wife know is like
unless is an absolute emergency on
Tuesdays when I'm writing my book don't
message me because I need to focus
because just responding to a message
puts me 40 minutes behind on my book cuz
I'm in the zone thinking about this
thing and I see this message even if I
don't answer the message what do they
want why is why is she calling why is
you know why is there why is that
popping up it distracts you and so you
don't do the work and then it's like
what was I writing over here I forgot
and you got to go back and you don't get
the work done and so especially for me
and for creative projects if I get
distracted I don't get my work done and
so I think it's really important to
eliminate the distractions that are
causing those headaches in your life way
number six is creating no crisis
business this is something that I
learned early on in my first business I
did not want to have crises happening I
didn't want to always have to be
responding to people immediately and
this this really comes from you training
the people around you but also bringing
in the people that you want to be around
and so I look at both my team and I look
at my customers my team I love mentoring
and guided my team but they also have to
be able to be independent and respect
boundaries if they can't then they're
not gonna be a good fit for my team if
you need constant supervision constant
like if you need me to be over your
shoulder to make something happen that's
the only way you work we're not gonna
work out well together I'm not gonna be
happy and you're not gonna be happy
because I don't like micromanaging
situations go work with a micromanager
and everybody will be happier for
customers some customers need need you
to be available 24/7 some customers
there's always a crisis is always a
problem they're just really needy people
and that's fine just not fine for me I
don't want to be around those kinds of
customers I'll turn away those kinds of
deals and you can often tell like
they're they're demanding they're pushy
they want things immediately and I love
giving good customer service but I also
need customers who respect the way that
I work and I'm gonna bring you insane
value for what I do and we have to trust
this process and if they can't get on
board with that then we don't work with
them as clients and it's fine because it
won't be a great experience for me or
them as well they won't get the results
that they're after either so let them go
work with somebody else who likes the
neediness and likes the the pain Holden
across
Street and so trying to adopt that
policy of running a no crisis business
has really really helped me in all the
businesses that I built and way number
seven is be around focused people you
know if you are around people who are
focus are hardworking are getting after
their thing you're much more likely to
do it as well right the environment
matters it's another consistent theme
that comes up in a lot of my videos the
people that you're around really matter
if you're around people who are always
joking always slacking up always trying
to find ways to cut corners I always
find ways to do the minimum possible
always just talking about movies and
sports and not actually doing work
you're gonna fall into that like part of
it's part of you is gonna be like that
and it's just really hard to shut that
thing off where if you're on people who
are focused productive trying to do big
things
accomplishing their mission getting work
done you're much more likely to go off
and be focused and productive as well
and so it's how do you find a space a
working environment that gives that to
you so if you're working from home maybe
you're working by yourself but maybe you
need a little bit of accompaniment so
maybe go to a coffee shop with these
people working maybe go to a co-working
space where there's other entrepreneurs
who are really hustling there trying to
get their business going even for me
watching the videos the top tens the the
mentor means all the videos I have on my
channel I see these people doing these
great things and as much of a focus hard
worker I am as much as I think I'm a you
know big thinker trying to do big things
for my you know businesses in my life I
look at some of these people these guys
are really focused really hard-working I
gotta I gotta up my game I got to
stretch my comfort zone I got to do more
I got to break some more limiting
beliefs and boundaries and go off and do
those things because those are the
people that I hang out with right Elon
Musk's and Steve Jobs and Zuckerberg and
those guys even if I'd never met them
and so paying really close attention to
the people that are around you and the
information you're consuming on a
regular consistent basis will have a
dramatic impact on your mindset on your
belief system and how focused you are at
work so thank you guys so much for
watching
I made this beauty because Suraj asked
me to if there's a topic you'd like me
to cover in a future several ways video
check out the link in the description go
and cast your vote and I might make a
video for you I love to know what did
you think of this one though which rule
had the biggest impact on you
that you're gonna start to apply
immediately somehow in your business or
your life leave it down in the comments
below also did I miss an 8 9 10 that you
want to contribute on how to stay more
focused I would love to hear from you
and I'm sure believe nation would to put
it down below I also want to give a
quick shoutout to John D Webster John
thank you so much for picking up a cup
of my book your one word and for doing
the review on your YouTube channel
I really really appreciate this
apartment and I'm so glad you enjoyed my
book so thank you again for watching I
believe in you I hope you continue to
believe in yourself
any whatever you're one where it is much
love I'll see you soon if you had to
think of one word that's most important
to you or that sums you up or so it
would be like a little beacon pay
believe nation if you want to know what
the most important one word is for Tony
Robbins Gary Vaynerchuk Oprah Winfrey
will.i.am and Howard Schultz I have a
very special secret video for you check
the description for details